sí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
esto es corresponsal es el programa de
france 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas les damos la
bienvenida a esta primera edición del
2022 que comenzamos en ecuador donde la
creación de una nueva zona de protección
marina en la provincia de galápagos uno
de los ecosistemas megadiversos del
planeta se convertirá en el corredor
natural para especies vulnerables más
grande de américa colombia ecuador
panamá y costa rica unirán esfuerzos
para la protección de especies en vía de
extinción y para la mitigación de la
crisis climática y aunque muchos de los
locales apoyan esta iniciativa otros
aseguran que podrían verse amenazados
sus empleos por las prohibiciones de
pesca y este es un reportaje de gustavo
ortega
armando barre suela ha vuelto de
realizar la labor de pesca más lejos de
lo habitual la prohibición de pesca a
30.000 km impuesta tras la creación de
la nueva zona marítima protegida en
galápagos ha cambiado su rutina de
trabajo y le genera inquietud también a
la nación que ingresa más pesca más más
pesca de gracias a la reserva pero no
tarda más en salir a pescar marius y que
viven de la pesca de su esposo del
mercado del pueblo señala que pescar más
lejos supone invertir de 300 a mil
quinientos dólares en combustibles
entonces eso de la reserva marina esté
bueno por una parte
ayuda pero por otra parte porque los
barcos de afuera de china todo eso aquí
al galapagueño le impiden el
producto de que hay aquí la reserva de
60 mil kilómetros recién declarada en
las islas ecuatorianas fue creada en pro
del ambiente en venta además de limitar
la pesca indiscriminada por parte de
flotas internacionales contribuir con la
preservación de las especies la
generación de oxígeno y ayudar con el
campo de la investigación a través de la
creación de la reserva hermandad hacemos
un llamado a todas las naciones del
mundo a unirse a este esfuerzo colectivo
y a preservar los bien reemplazado los
tesoros del océano otras opiniones de
pescadores varían de la de armando louis
apoyo al corredor marítimo y espera que
sea una mayor fuente abastecimiento y
reserva de biósfera del planeta
habría menos captura de peces por la
parte extranjera
ya que los ecuatorianos tanto en la
parte continental que también al segundo
de esa también tendrían derecho de
vuelta en el mercado armando aplaude que
se rescaten las especies con esta nueva
zona de protección sin embargo espera
que con el corredor marítimo la pesca
artesanal y los 1.100 pescadores que
hacen vida en galápagos también queden
protegidos
y la inflación que golpea el mundo de
manera generalizada está afectando a los
económicamente vulnerables en estados
unidos un país que alcanzó un 7% de
inflación en 2021 las familias latinas
se han visto particularmente golpeadas
ya que ven como el dinero rinde menos y
han tenido que buscar ayuda en los
bancos de alimentos este es un reportaje
de mamen sanz
madeleine y su pequeño de nueve meses
acuden a un banco de alimentos para
recoger la comida que consumirán en la
semana
como ella cientos de personas dependen
de esta ayuda porque con el aumento de
los precios de los alimentos en un 63
por ciento en los últimos 12 meses
les resulta imposible llenar la canasta
alimentaria
dinero te alcanza para nada vas a
comprar con una cantidad de dinero y no
te basta porque está todo todo con el
precio muy alto
es el efecto de la inflación- que golpea
a eeuu
en las familias se les hace muy difícil
y por lo tanto también digamos si antes
teníamos 950 familias que distribuíamos
y damos una bolsa muy grande tuvimos que
reducir porque no puede hay muchas cosas
que están muy caras realmente
esta dominicana y su pequeño de 9 meses
viven con su marido y su suegra en la
misma casa los cuatro tienen que llegar
a fin de mes con dos mil dólares antes
estoy va con 50 dólares y podrías
comprar huevo carne un poquito de queso
y verduras ahora no grabas con 50
dólares y apenas puedes comprar tal vez
2 verduras y un poquito de carne el
aumento del precio de la luz les ha
obligado a cambiar las rutinas la
televisión solo se enciende dos horas al
día y las luces casi siempre están
apagadas antes estábamos pagando 30 32
dólares
al mes ahora la factura está llegando de
60 a 70 75 dólares detrás de la
inflación dicen los expertos que hay
varios motivos entre ellos la escasez de
trabajadores la crisis energética y uno
importante falta de abastecimiento
provocada por esos atascos en las
cadenas de suministro
ginette ha sido testigo de cómo las
estanterías de este supermercado están
cada vez más vacías siempre soy así no
ahora con la crisis ser capaz ya eso
cuánto cuesta
si 9 kos y fuerte y 3
casi 20 dólares por 4 kilos de pollo
según los economistas los precios están
cerca de alcanzar su punto máximo y a
partir de ahí comenzarán a estabilizarse
aunque también advierten que pasarán
meses hasta verse las mejoras
y concluyó en camerún la copa africana
de naciones en la que senegal levantó
por primera vez el título continental
tras derrotar a egipto en la tanda de
penales un evento que contó con un
cubrimiento especial por parte de france
24 y nuestros enviados visitaron además
la asociación esportiva ramas a un club
amateur catalán que utiliza el fútbol
como herramienta de transformación
social esta historia ocurre en ete tag
un barrio de bajos recursos en los
márgenes de johann de la capital y este
es un reportaje de federico fue
barberena y patrick lamont
en este pequeño rincón de ella donde se
habla español
ubicado en las afueras de la capital
camerunesa el barrio de teta que se
conecta con cataluña a través de la
asociación esportiva ramas a este
modesto club llegó en 2017 como parte de
una de sus giras solidarias anuales por
áfrica pero en este taller la
institución se involucró en un proyecto
que va más allá de lo futbolístico con
la misión de ayudar a la comunidad a
gestionar las carencias diarias como
destaca uno de los jefes de la zona
el proyecto ramas aporta muchas cosas e
incluso ha alcanzado a la alcaldía es
gracias a esto que el alcalde viene a
menudo a animarnos a seguir el proyecto
somos de scouts bajo los colores de
ramas squash niños y niñas del barrio
acceden a clases de apoyo escolar y de
idiomas como español e inglés
también cuentan con escuelas de danza
que van desde el baile contemporáneo
a música y cantos tradicionales
clases de mecánica y de peluquería son
opciones para aquellos jóvenes que
abandonan los estudios
el corazón del proyecto en el terreno es
william vianda quien coordina las
actividades del club en este tac además
de liderar la escuela de fútbol que
reúne a un centenar de niños y también
niñas aunque las clases trascienden la
pelota para nosotros no se trata
simplemente hablar de fútbol pero el
fútbol nos sirve como herramienta que
pone la gente junto y luego podemos
transmitir las valores porque para
nosotros lo más importante son las
valores humanas es por esperanza esa es
la palabra más repetida por los alumnos
enviadme de tango
japan con más salud
acceso al agua potable y luminarias en
las calles y mejoras en los ingresos al
barrio son algunas de las necesidades
por cubrir meta que por ahora cuentan
con ramas el único apoyo tangible que ha
tenido este pueblo olvidado de yaundé
un monopolio para luchar contra las
desigualdades este es el concepto creado
por el observatorio de las desigualdades
de francia
una idea que tardó tres años en
desarrollarse en una escuela secundaria
parisina en los jóvenes utilizaron este
tradicional juego de mesa pero con
algunas modificaciones que los invitaron
a reflexionar de manera lúdica sobre las
injusticias que plagan a la sociedad el
siguiente es un reportaje de hembra dmax
y miriam bengie light
estos niños están a punto de jugar al
monopolio pero no el tradicional aquí
los jugadores no empiezan la partida en
igualdad de condiciones
[Música]
a cada niño se le asigna un papel al
azar y algunos son más privilegiados que
otros el monopolio ha sido adaptado por
el observatorio de las desigualdades
para ser utilizado con fines educativos
[Música]
el objetivo es realmente informarle
sobre el estado de las desigualdades en
francia sin encerrarlos en una
observación fatalista en la que salgan
de una sesión diciendo que en cualquier
caso las desigualdades son tales que no
tiene sentido intentarlo y que su futuro
ya está trazado de antemano de redhat
sepamos
estos escolares de la capital francesa
descubren que algunos son más iguales
que otros
es para mostrar las desigualdades pero
el hecho de enfrentarse a eso
directamente pues no me gustó porque
pensé que en la vida real hay gente que
realmente vive eso pero más duro
las reglas del juego fueron diseñadas
para reflejar la realidad
una línea para ser zhang a
los trenes actuales sería mejor asignar
rampas por ejemplo en el tr en el rr
para las personas en silla de ruedas la
herramienta del juego funciona muy bien
para que discutan un tema que es
complicado un tema social que puede ser
difícil excepto que no tenemos
suficiente tiempo cada vez para entrar
en todo por eso es muy importante para
nosotros trabajar en colaboración con
los profesores o educadores para que
puedan continuar el trabajo que
iniciamos con esta sesión a excepción
[Música]
preguntas difíciles abordadas con un
enfoque original el observatorio de las
desigualdades espera promover reglas más
justas para todo el mundo y continuamos
en francia país que conmemora los 400
años del nacimiento de molière el
espacio de versalles inauguró una
exposición titulada moli a la fábrica de
una gloria nacional que estará
disponible hasta mediados de abril en
total 200 obras entre archivos
manuscritos y vestuarios escénicos
componen esta exposición que sus
organizadores han calificado como una
oportunidad única para adentrarse en los
secretos del dramaturgo francés más
famoso de la historia
mauricio usted y sonia patricelli nos
cuentan todo
creíamos saberlo todo sobre moler sin
embargo no se conservó ningún manuscrito
original de su obra y poco se sabe de su
vida
las historias han cambiado con los
regímenes políticos la exposición muller
la fábrica de una gloria nacional
pretende de construir el mito para
restablecer la verdad histórica
al estudiar a molière su vida descubrí
que era un hombre hiperactivo que tenía
múltiples trabajos fue actor autor
director de compañía y también tapicero
del rey se dice que incluso antes de
morir estuvo a punto de fallecer por
fatiga y enfermedades
desde trajes de época reconstruidos
hasta máscaras de ira y feli realizadas
para la película popular la colección
reúne cerca de 200 obras porque molière
no sólo es un tesoro nacional sino ton
en el dramaturgo francés más leído
representado y traducido del mundo
actual
la exposición da un gran lugar a las
giras de los artistas franceses en el
extranjero hay un texto muy conmovedor
sobre una gira de jean billar por áfrica
en el que explica que aplicados y
franceses pueden reconocerse juntos
misma referencia y es también lo que es
más interesante el autor que ha sido re
apropiado por diferentes culturas y en
particular por las culturas que
participaron durante varios siglos en el
proyecto de colonización de francia y
que finalmente se quedó con molina para
poder explicarnos que este teatro que
habla de los matrimonios concertados que
habla del dominio de la religión sobre
la sociedad es de hecho también un
teatro para nuestro tiempo en diferentes
regiones del mundo y que sólo
remotamente se refiere a la sociedad
francesa del siglo 17
[Música]
en su época moliére era una estrella hoy
en día es una referencia indiscutible su
obra ha vivido por cuatro siglos de
historia y sigue tan vigente como
siempre
gracias por acompañarnos queremos
agradecer a la biblioteca pública a
virgilio barco de bibliored por la
oportunidad de grabar nuestro programa
en sus instalaciones sigan con más
información en france24 france24
puntocom